welcome back at gamers we're playing
more terraria this game is so fun let's
jump it to me
hey hey hey hey alright we have this guy
came now a good day to die I agree he
sounds dynamite I think I'll buy some
dynamite oh yeah wait there's one more
guy where is he where the hell is he
Oh God there was another guy okay well
whatever
hey squirrel alright so now it's daytime
oh sorry oh sorry now we can run fast
and everyone's been saying I should
explore left and right so I'm doing that
all year so fast that is very annoying
it's worth fixing night again very
annoying
maybe it's faster just place blocks yes
oh man I'm so fast
okay so this is where I ran in just keep
going this way then I assume there's a
limit to how far you can go
good thing I have the boots because wow
they're so useful Oh purple slime nice
alright we're in the desert
hopefully whoa whoa whoa what Papa stab
it like prison hopefully by this we'll
get the AVA could throw a boss I want to
do that by the end well like this
what snow there's snow in Terraria how I
climb whoo the music is great brothers
penguins that's so cool
am I not wearing my mining helmet
whoa that's so cool bro I'm so cool
do you see how cool I get it because
it's called a time haha okay sorry
then you're all dead well what does this
okay we're entering spooky biome
question mark what is this funky biome
question mark oh god no where do you go
all right calm down all right
don't think so this is corruption zoom
out oh thanks yeah I got him this is
fine oh god oh jesus lord they're many
[Music]
they keep coming
leave me alone okay we're safe devourer
Oh God
[Music]
alright we're fighting we're battling
it's cool we're making pro gamer moves
hoji says Lord I can devour my ass pit
yes yeah alright we're back in the
desert there's a lot harmless more
harmless night well we made it through
lovely biome
alright we're going through gaming oh
okay
allows collection of vines okay is that
good her back okay can we drop dynamite
down there
Oh
[Music]
enchanted sword whoa
20 excuse me what what what what oh my
god the sword is amazing Oh
one day you're mining the other day
you're finding a 1x1 sword in the hole
bye-bye
does that mean we're ready for the I
come on I can take the I come on I'm all
ready for the I why should I be prepared
for it I want to get a bunch of potions
make a platforms that's a good idea too
actually
let's just go for it why so many zombies
coming now like chill bro all right here
he comes
we're doing it oh Jesus
price that's big oh god I need to switch
sides with you buddy shoots tiny
lowlifes
Jesus why it's so nasty yes
eat it eat it all brah he's let's go
No God come on baby come on don't freak
out you've got this Felix easy oh
alright halfway oh god what is that
Oh God Oh chase I'm done I'm done I'm
officially done
you nasty boy
oh god no it's not like this come on
what is on like 0% no no oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you feel the platform
they said run out of time you say I'm
thank alright so what do we get wait
raincoat yeah I have Cthulhu can be
placed
what whoa okay done I have a zombie arm
where did I get that from demon ID or
whoa okay I can make it whoa a demon bow
or a malice or should I make I like that
is that a joke oh yeah save it for the
pickaxe I think that makes sense
so I can just keep summoning him what
the guide NPC who say yes saves your
name
so you mean ask Connor what I can do the
pickaxe costs 18 no I can make the
pickaxe
I just need shadow scale whatever that
is can I mind this now what is that all
right here we are there's a lot
underneath this there has to be
somewhere mining potion gamers or this
is money laying around here that sounds
like famous last words this is a pattern
all right we're somehow okay cheese says
how we're still going downwards wha what
is this oh god oh and over in house it's
getting
she says I didn't expect this
Oh God okay what are you going to do a
little chain lick the real chili should
say pathetic make myself a little
comfortable here
in hell what's up Satan it's me I've
returned Oh God Jesus Lord I was not
paying attention can I mind through this
okay all right
obsidian workbench we got a lovely
paintings instant time to throw away
some stuff
it's a slimy can't hurt me that looks
more dangerous this try grab that what
do I do with that yeah okay so I have a
better furnace cool nice that's cozy now
I can grab the mushroom Lantern mushroom
door Rushton chandelier Barra sure I'll
make some chandelier Brera who wants the
mushroom chandelier Barra Katie you get
it what the hell is happening sorry
Scarlett you were literally running
towards me thank you Jesus cool that's
us
that's cool I have so much stuff I'm so
lost
obsidian piano over one thing that's
collection I'll give him a furnace just
for like decorations see guess it makes
sense for this guy to have a detonator
that's kind of cool right so now I have
the armor set right we're going out
gamers we're going out murdering
beautiful animals because we're go into
corruption area
is that something nah okay a Desert
Storm
Jesus Christ what is that don't think so
cute penguins dead the cute penguins and
we're entering corruption some action I
guess that makes sense it seemed to have
destroyed sunflower coal I can't place
it anyway thanks for the tip guys so
what do I do here
alright this hole is big very large hole
here guys is this yes nice give me a
fresh Oh demonite or nice Oh
how do I get through it alright bomb
time okay oh no problem
yeah all right what is this what is this
I blow up their works whoa alright let's
use dynamite it's taking too long
[Laughter]
screams echo around you I think now stop
stop it feelings go back well why the
hell did you tell me to go ahead to
begin with you know my site get out of
my sight I'm getting advice from people
I don't follow
I got an umbrella that's okay wait what
is this
we found jungle biome gamers I only kill
one boss oh geez not a fun night another
crop and I'm out
thank you all year Jesus be like bruh
what weight that is at the end at the
end gamers can't write them hmm
it's kind of cold up a meteorite has
landed excuse me what the plan
I must get 31 damage isn't that good gun
dude it has a mother
alright let's go left this time slime is
falling from the sky oh god it's so many
goddamn it get up slimes thank you oh
Jesus
keeps raining slime all day a slime all
night wasn't ready
oh I'm sorry king slime I'm sorry I
messed up I know I shouldn't have done
it
let's blow him up just made the rains
okay shooting with a gun because that's
what gamers do oh god he can teleport
like oh god it I hit G instead of H are
you kidding me I was not paying
attention at all what a failure become
one side is oh god no sir play Oh keeps
going after me this is as far as I've
ever gone and oh my god literally there
it is
old man hello old man my master cannot
be summoned under the light of day who's
your master nice place
I didn't mean cows paraphrasing sorry
I want these give me these these are
mine who's the master
I didn't find the meteor I can go
further all right
whoa this is so pretty and it's gone oh
this is beach biome I'm gonna drown
I guess I'll you should go to the ocean
when I have like water potion thing all
right so what's down here then mine
everyone says don't go down I'm getting
a lot of nose that's who's that why did
you not tell me oh my god unbelievable
all right it's getting dark now we can
talk to the guy he's got a run across
the map again bloody moon rising what
does that mean what the hell is this
this is what the meteor Wow
[Music]
Jesus Christ what is happening so what
do I do
mine it but I burn up if I go down there
why do they sound like popcorns that's
why I need obsidian yeah but I don't
know how to get it obsidian
oh wow they come through the round what
kill me even atoms what what that what
is happening uh are you okay
who are you what is all this
who are you this place is getting bigger
and bigger
oh god they're in my house how did this
did I forget the door open
they can open door what what do I do
nope done cool
problem solved what is happening what
happened to this game hey you should be
so innocent man my akia hotel is don't
pretty good man like the business
booming absolutely good everybody loved
IKEA with that why should I go I feel
like there's so many things I can do
like the media or the guy is something
the hell or and it was like oh you're
not ready but it's like well what is the
next thing to do then like legitimately
hey we survived hey come back guys come
on get off my property
anyone trespassing is shot come back
shoot the bird shoot the bird
shoot the bird got him I think I got it
oh god oh god oh god I'm burning up oh I
didn't see that God I was a hog fine
fine this fireman is running for no
reason come on that desert is so tiny
is it cuz the corruption to go over it
no no not like this I'm not in it I
didn't see it as stupid God
Chinese Lantana so cool why does it not
place it there we go just don't know
where I'm jumping it's so dark
they really got them zoomed in on me
getting a lot of stars
Jesus no we're not doing that
mm-hmm I'm done I'm done
only cowards quit and I am a coward
let's go
hey squirrel permabanned to whoever this
is my house why is somebody something
okay spawn point set hey nuke time you
will die for what you wait why do I
place it so far away ah I don't get you
know what we're gonna do now platform
you ever heard of this we're gonna nuke
it from above is what I wanted to do
last time oh my god I hate actually
they're so annoying
I am literally on fire because of them
[Music]
I don't know what it's doing I hear boom
this is what boomers do stop what's left
of this meteor I am so confused
am i burning I was burning up
I don't even realize there's no fire
there there is no fire there collect
what collect why why I don't see
anything it's a hole how do I collect
the hole this is firming this is burn me
what burns me I'm so confused
collect the whole yeah okay cool I'll
get the whole what's happening have I
been trolled for the past one hour
what is this Jesus Christ that I bombed
this place what the hell is this now
what nope are they gonna stop coming now
are they keep gonna be annoying is that
the meteor I have the or hi meteorite
okay there it is oh and now came a
meteor part okay got it
oh whoa I got a lot of it oh wow now can
do about it okay
alright cool I can make a space gun what
should I make suit speights gut I feel
like space gun make the pickaxe you
can't make the tank x6 defense instead
of 5 defense doesn't seem that appealing
it is my musket not better than space
guns that one this 31 okay I can craft a
lot of stuff I can do all of it damn no
that is so dumb set bonus space gun cost
mana
is it working you can shoot the gun
forever okay so that hell I went through
was worth it cool
good to know no point in the musket now
is it what I can make a lightsaber which
color doesn't matter
no all right I'll be the same what are
you what is this game what is this game
at this point why are there no
lightsabers in Minecraft
all right where do I go next come on
tell me oh god I'm so sorry I just blew
up my house I just blew I just I just
put a giant hole in my house for no
reason
who does that Jesus Christ this game is
ridiculous when you think it can't get
any sillier it just gets somehow more
underground jungle okay where did we see
a junk boat did we see it this way or
was it that way
alright I kind of want the helmet though
it's
[Music]
I'm dead oh my god oh my lime did I
manage to grab on to that one
whoa okay that gun is awesome
Jesus the gun is amazing what is that
Jesus Christ okay nice we got another
what is hurting me all the time
okay we got it we got it I got it I got
it I got it I got it I don't like the
jungle I'm gonna say it now I don't like
the jungle things keep hurting me and I
don't see what it is I'm gonna chill
here why does this sword suck so much
go nibble someone else titties oh my god
what a difference that story stop
shooting me stop Jesus that was close
Oh God why I didn't see the bad they're
so small they're so tiny I can't see
them I thought the thing was just
shooting me and I'm like oh I'm safe
here no fat kills you great fun so where
was it it's not in the first hole arm in
there it's like in the second Jesus
Christ your gun is amazing
what's it down here yeah it looks like
see what I want to use the [ __ ] mining
helmet Jesus Christ I don't know why I
listen to you guys
I know take them on I forgot why do I am
not listening
[Music]
here we go gamer easy alright look at
this alright Jesus Christ what is that
oh I shot up his [ __ ] in each and
dying oh god there's two of them oh this
complicates things let's complicate
things so much leave me alone I want out
of this place
there's like a million of them there's
two millions of them there's five
million of them billion billion I
counted I'm getting this son brother
getting the suck they're getting the
suck they're getting the suck come on
come on eat my balls and marinate them
yeah that's right that's right that's
freakin right 100 million all right what
do I get
where's the loop I can make the pickaxe
okay apparently now I can make a pickaxe
to do the thing that I've been meaning
to do does have a bunch of Humanite part
Jesus Christ I have a lot of rock I've
been playing all day
nightmare pickaxe whoa
I can mine anything in the game gamers
look at that whoa warts fast don't mind
the squirrel see if it works
oh wow
all right guys hope you guys enjoyed
that episode epic especially like if you
want more terraria and I see you guys
next time
hey doll hey hey we're all excited about
the new game that's coming out and I
can't wait to play it it starts with the
letter P can you guess what it is here
the PI pick ceiling of course what you
thought it was Pokemon dumbass you
stinky brainer
you